hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute backen wir mit samira zusammen
cheesecake brown ist und zwar sind promi
so richtig schön schokoladig saftig und
einfach schön weich und heute ist
kombinieren wir diesen leckeren schoko
brauche ich jetzt mal mit einem
käsekuchen und dann noch mit frischen
himbeeren also mit die himbeeren besser
gesagt ja dein hund guckt wieder zu
genau da oben ist da sitzt darf nämlich
nicht in die küche geld genau und wir
zeigen jetzt ganz kurz mal die zutaten
und dann länger direkt los an zutaten
brauchen wir 125 gramm butter 150 gramm
zucker 100 gramm zarter schokolade etwas
vanille extrakt und einer prise salz 250
gramm zucker drops 100 gramm mehl und 30
km kakaopulver und für den cheesecake
brauchen wir 250 g frischkäse 50 gramm
und jetzt starten wir direkt erstmal mit
dem braun
dafür gebe ich jetzt die schokolade und
die butter in einen kleinen topf und das
muss dann darin erst nach schmelzen so
einfach auf niedriger stufe stellen
und ich habe jetzt auch hier schon mal
meine form gerichtet und zwar nehme ich
mal den eckigen back rahmen und habe ihn
auf kleinster stufe gestellt also auf 20
x 30 cm
während die frei zutaten gerade noch im
topf schmelzen kann ich schon mal diese
cheesecake füllung machen und zwar nehme
ich dafür den frischkäse und gebt denen
eine glasschüssel wir brauchen jetzt
dafür auch kein handrührgerät es geht
alles ganz gut mit schneebesen und mit
einem kochlöffel als auch ein sehr
einfaches rezept
da kommt der puderzucker mit rein
dienstlich durch damit ich keine münchen
habe
dann kommt hier noch ein bisschen
vanille extrakt rein fürs leckere aroma
und das jetzt kann ich die zutaten erst
einmal miteinander verrühren warte ich
früher kurz ein bisschen und dann darf
so weiter
jetzt ist die schokolade geschmolzen
gemeinsam mit der butter und die kann er
jetzt in einer rührschüssel geben
also ich habs jetzt auch nicht heiß
werden lassen sondern wirkt einfach nur
schmelzen lassen die sie nicht so warm
macht es und händewaschen
was soll ich da sagen
dann gebe ich jetzt mal heller extrakt
mit dazu und jetzt kommen einfach noch
die restlichen zutaten mit rein also die
trockenen schoko drops etwas salz und
zucker und dann ruhig das alles kurz
durch
jetzt fühle ich den teig in meine
vorbereitete form ein und verstreichen
darin
jetzt verteidigt die käsemasse drüber
und jetzt maria ich die frauen noch mit
einer gabel
jetzt kommen darauf der gefrorenen bernd
rauw
in
ich bräuchte ein fahrrad ein aufgebot
hat
die promis werden jetzt im vorgeheizten
ofen bei 180 grad ober unterhitze für
ungefähr 25 minuten gebacken die braune
sind gebacken ich habe sie auch abkühlen
lassen und auch für etwa eine halbe
stunde bis stunde in den kühlschrank
gestellt
jetzt kann ich sie aus der form
herauslösen das hier war auch richtig
lust auf die brauche es jetzt ich auch
ich habe übrigens schon t hingerichtet
ich weiß durch den ganzen tag diese tk
mit
sieht richtig lecker aus muratow darf
probieren denn du kannst dann auch gut
aus der hand sitzt einfach essen
ich glaube ich habe den besten job der
welt und ich glaube auch ich glaube
viele beneiden dich um diesen job als
tester lecker
ich finde die kombination ist richtig
gut also mir läuft hat echtes wasser im
mund zusammen dieser schokolade gezeigt
dann dünne nicht so süße frischkäse
schicht die bringt da so diese frische
rein und dann eben noch dieser
neuerlichen himbeeren richtig gut als
auch kenianische weiß dass vision märkte
oder boden ist genial
der boden ist ein bisschen härter und so
richtig dass verschiedene konsistenten
gewünschten dann merkst du diese dieses
gelbe was ist es noch mal wissen ja wie
frischkäse und in den exzellent und
plötzlich kommt dann diese himberg genau
hat man echt eine geschmacksexplosion
wirklich richtig cool
der boden ist richtig toll und wie
gesagt diese frisch creme und dann diese
hunde
ich finde diesen auch nicht zu schwer
also wie normale wieso normale browning
ist ja also wenn ihr das rezept nach
machen wollt geht einfach auf meinem
blog de da stelle ich euch noch mal rein
wir machen gleich unsere fotos findet
blog da könnt ihr könnt ihr euch die
auch anschauen und dann sehen wir uns
beim nächsten mal wieder bis auf
wiedersehen ging ja wirklich nicht ohne
chance